beginning as a friendly wager between
shell engineers in the 1930s about who
could travel furthest on the least
amount of fuel the shell eco marathon
has grown to become a hub of
technological innovation for generations
of students who are challenged inspired
and supported by shell to dream up ultra
energy efficient vehicles
my name is benjamin escrow i am a part
of the sask eco marathon team
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so you've been inspired to create an
urban concept vehicle for the shell eco
marathon well according to the team at
saskatchewan polytechnic you will need
the following ingredients
a lawn chair
a dismantled drill a 3d printer
and some inspiration
throughout my childhood i would play
hockey games and now that i'm older and
in school during my spare time i referee
hockey games
i joined the team they put me on the
frame crew i didn't know
what to make the frame out of andrew
explained to me he's like i have an idea
crazy idea you want to hear me out and i
was like sure what do you think of
hockey sticks carbon fiber hockey sticks
hockey to canada is the national sport
we wish we had
because lacrosse is the national sport
with the shell eco marathon the goal is
to reduce your energy consumption as
much as possible we want to be
responsible with the resources we've
been given repurposing
the hockey sticks the water bottle the
the body shell itself is a recyclable
plastic we came in with no expectations
actually my expectation was to go around
the track once and i would have been
extremely happy
[Music]
just the atmosphere at shelley marathon
is is awesome everyone is interested in
what you do everyone's very friendly and
open i would recommend anyone to come
who has an open mind and wants to learn
every vehicle that competes is
completely different
well this whole experience is kind of
life-changing until i was on the plane
in london it just didn't seem real
they're looking for teams to
come forward with new ideas and see what
young kids have in their minds right you
know that we make the future right
it's pretty cool
you